翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Reiko Bovee
はじめに 皆さまに質問があります
あなたの想いは 何ですか？
2015年の秋 私はアメリカに行って
ある政府派遣事業の一員として
東北の復興について話す機会がありました
被災地が いまだに大変な状況であること
しかし 同時に
たくさんの個人の人々が東北に訪れて
東北で活動をして 東北に貢献している
ということを紹介しました
最初の日に —
プログラムの最初の日に
私はある大学に行って
その講演をした後
聴衆から一人の女性が
私の元に来てくれました
その女性は 長年アメリカに住んでいる
日本人の方でした
そしてその方に
次のように言われました
「あなたのスピーチは 本当にひどかった
あなたは 東北出身でもないんでしょう？
被災地に訪れたことがあるの？
今のスピーチを被災者の方が聞いたら
とても悲しむと思うわ
被災地が いまだに
あんなに大変な状況なのに
あなたのスピーチは
あまりにもポジティブで前向き過ぎた
今のスピーチ 一度録音して
被災者の方々に聞かせてみなさい
きっと皆さん 気分悪くされるわよ」
私はこれを聞いて
あまりにも予想外なコメントで
ついショックを受けてしまいました
私は何度も被災地を訪れ
被災者の方々ともお話をしましたし
実際に 東北の人々とも
一緒に行動をしていたつもりです
それでも 疑われてしまうということは
自分の中でどこか疑わしい要素が
あるのではないかと
疑わしい要素があるとしたら
それはきっと
自分が東北出身ではない
東北ではなく 別のところから来た
ただの「よそ者」である
その事実が疑わしいのではないかと
こんなよそ者がなぜ
東北について語る権利などあるのか？
そう言われているような気がして
とても悲しくなりました
ではなぜ私は東北について
話していたのでしょうか？
私は大阪生まれで
５歳から11歳半をアメリカで過ごしました
アメリカで過ごしていた当初から
自分は日本人だっていう
強いアイデンティティーの意識を持っていて
周りのアメリカ人の友達にも
日本がどれほど魅力的で素晴らしい国かについて
いつも話していました
しかし アメリカから帰国して
日本の小学校に転校した時に初めて
「あ もしかしたら 私はよそ者かも？」
と思ったことがありました
それは 日本の小学校での
給食の時間でした
アメリカではこのような
紙パックの牛乳を飲みます
カフェテリアに行って
ランチの時間に
皆んな 自分の好きな食べ物を
取るんですけど
このような紙パックの牛乳が置いてあります
日本の小学校で
給食の時間になった時に
私が渡されたのは
この画面にある牛乳びん —
ガラスのやつです
私はこのガラスの牛乳びんの
開け方が分かりませんでした
色々と試行錯誤して
このガラスの牛乳びんを開けようとして
やっと開いたと思ったら
牛乳がドバッと 外に出てしまいました
「あれ？どうなったんだろう？」
と思ったんですけど
周りで見ていたクラスメートが
それを見て 皆んな 指をさして
「ああ あなたは アメリカ人だから
そんなことも出来ないんだ」と言われました
当時の私は小学校６年生でしたが
すごく悲しかったことを覚えています
「私は 日本人なのに
なんでアメリカ人って呼ばれたんだろう？」と
幼少時代を 日本ではなく
アメリカで過ごしたことで
やっぱりどこか 自分の言動が
周りとはちょっと違って
見えてしまうことがあります
そしてその違いっていうのは
やっぱりどうしても目立ってしまって
その目立つ度に
「ああ あなた 帰国子女だからね」
という風に言われます
それ自体は 仕方ないと思うんですけれども
やはりどうしても 自分の中で
自分のアイデンティティーに対する
葛藤がありました
私は日本人なのに
なんでこの母国であるはずの日本で
ちょっと違う人 —
「よそ者」のように見られるのかなと
ずっと疑問に思っていました
それでも 私は日本が大好きで
日本に貢献したいとずっと思い続けました
大学に進学しまして
その時に東京に行ったんですけれども
上京して しばらく経ってから
震災が起きました
そして 震災を機に
私は東北での活動に関わり始めました
その東北での活動で
様々な人に出会いました
もちろん 中には東北出身の方もいましたが
他の地域から来ている人 —
例えば東京だとか
たまにアメリカとか
ヨーロッパとか
オーストラリアとかの海外 —
アジアですとか
様々なところから
わざわざ東北に来て
東北で貢献したい —
そしてその活動している方々に出会いました
そんな方々がいる東北地方に
私は非常に刺激を受け
そんな東北地方に恋をしてしまいました
よく地域活性化論で
「若者 よそ者 馬鹿者が地域を盛り上げる」
という風に
確かにまあ 「よそ者」などのアクターは
地域活性化にとても重要かも知れません
で 実際にこのようなアクターを
地域に誘致しようと
全国各地で このような取り組みが
行われています
しかし 皆さまご存知の通り
現在日本は 東京一極集中
そして少子化によって 人口減少に
悩まされている地域がたくさんあります
全国ランキングを見てみますと
人口減少率が最も高い都道府県の
上位にあるのは 例えば
秋田県 福島県 青森県 山形県 岩手県など
結構東北地方の県も
上位にあって目立っています
このように
人口減少に悩まされている地域がある中
たくさんの自治体が
この人口減少に歯止めをかけようと
いろんな取り組みを実施しています
そして 一つ その中に実施されているのは
移住者を呼ぶことです
移住者 — 外からその地域に移住される方
そういう方々を誘致して 人口を増やそうと
そのような取り組みが 政府でも
地方創生の政策の一環として推奨されていて
各自治体に そのような取り組みを
するようにと促しています
人口の社会増 つまり
転入者が増えてきている地域の一つとして
徳島県神山町があります
そしてこのような —
徳島県神山町のような
移住者が大変増えている地域では
移住者がメインとなって運営している
カフェですとかイベントですとか
コミュニティスペースですとか
そういったものが たくさん立ち上がっていて
地域が盛り上がってきています
他にも 外からどんどん
地域を訪れている所の例としまして
岡山県倉敷市
福岡県糸島市
島根県海士（あま）町などがあります
そしてこれらの地域は 全部
とても魅力的な地域として
今 注目を浴びています
確かに このような外からの人 —
「よそ者」は
地域にとても重要かも知れません
しかし よそ者だから大事と
私は言いたいわけではありません
よそ者だから価値がある
帰国子女だからちょっと違う
留学生だから 新しい視点を持っている
日本人だから そのような行動をする —
私は こういう理由づけは
ちょっと違うと思います
誰かの立場によって その人の
貢献度合いや価値が変わるわけではありません
大事なのは その人の「想い」
その人が その地域に
どんな愛情があるのか
自分の活動の裏に
どのような願いがあるのか
この想いが大事だと思います
好きだから貢献したい
自分の活動だとか
その地域の人々だとか
その地域全体だとか
何かしらその地域にいることが
すごく好きで
その地域にいたいから
貢献したいと思える
私はこのような想いを
持たれている方々がいる東北地方に
すごくインスピレーションを受けまして
そんな東北地方が大好きになりました
東北で出会った 一人の女性がいます
イタリア人の女性です
この方は 当時はスペインのバルセロナに
住んでいたのですけれども
震災の後 自分の貯金を崩して
年に何度も東北地方を訪れて
東北の人々と話して勉強をし
自分の活動を始めました
現在この方はお子様を連れて
岩手県遠野市に移住して
活動を続けておられます
私はこのような強い想いを持たれて
それを行動に移されている方々に出会い
私もそのような人になりたいと思って
自分の想いを形にしようと思いました
そして 東北に
何度も訪れるようになりました
例えば 会津若松市
会津の文化
そして会津の人々に出会って
私はこんなに良い所があるなんて
知らなかったと
本当にその時は思いました
そして 会津が本当に好きになって
毎年訪れるほど
すごく好きになりました
会津の魅力をもっといろんな人に
知ってもらいたいと思い
私はある日 大学院の留学生の友達を
皆んな連れて行って
会津の地元の方々と連携をして
会津漆器と食文化を
楽しむツアーを企画しました
また 別の機会で
アジアからのデザイナーを誘致して
東北の地元の企業の事業主さんと一緒に
コラボレーションをして
新しいコミュニケーションデザインを
築き上げようというプログラム —
このプログラムの通訳としても参加しました
普段だったら出会うこともない
このアジアのデザイナーたちと
東北の地元企業の事業主さんが
一緒に１〜２週間ぐらい過ごして
そして一緒に
新しいコミュニケーションデザインを
つくっていく —
このような機会に
私は携わることができました
そしてあとは 冒頭にもお伝えした通り
政府の派遣事業による
アメリカでの東北の復興についての講演
これらすべて 私の東北に対する
想いから生まれたものです
それだけではありません
私は東北での経験を通じて
他の地方の魅力も知りたいと
思うようになりました
そして 他の地方の魅力を知って
その魅力をどんどん
世界へと発信して行きたい
「地方からの外交」
発信という意味での外交 —
これが 現在の私の
ライフワークとなっています
地方からの外交を
人材育成という観点から追求するため
私は現在 福岡に住んでいて
福岡での英語塾に勤めています
福岡の子どもたちが
英語学習を通じて
英語が好きになり
自分の英語力に自信を持って
全国 そして世界へと
羽ばたけるような人材になってもらいたい
そんな願いで 今 働いています
驚くことに
この子どもたちは
英語を好きになっていくだけではなく
英語を好きになる過程を通じて
どんどん自分の夢を
具体的に持てるようになっています
例えば 全く英語に関心のなかった子が
海外留学を目指してみたいとか
海外に住んでみたい
英語を使った仕事に就いてみたいなど
日々そのような成長が見られて
私自身もすごく驚いています
このように何か一つを
小さいことでも良いんですけど
何か一つを徐々に好きになっていくと
その好きという気持ちがだんだん
より大きな そして
より具体的な夢へとなっていきます
好きという気持ちが
自分の想いを育ててくれて
自分の想いが徐々に夢へとなる
そして自分の夢が
他の誰かの想いを強めてくれて
その人の想いがその人の夢へとなる
この 想いの連鎖こそが
社会に大きなインパクトを
与えるのではないかと思います
よそ者だとか何者だとか
そういったことではなく
結局大事なのは その想い —
その人の想いだと思います
私は東北のおかげで
地方に目を向けることができました
そして 東北のおかげで
自分の世界も広がり
そして自分の夢も
具体的に描けるようになりました
結局のところ
人は 自分の立場とか
アイデンティティーとか
レッテルとかではなくて
自分の想い 自分の何かを好きという気持ちが
どのような夢へと向かっているのか？
その想いのベクトルが大事です
冒頭でもお伝えした通り
私は政府派遣事業でアメリカで
東北の復興事業について
講演していました
そしてそのプログラムは一週間
様々な有識者の許で講演をしていきました
正直 初日に言われたコメントが
非常にグサッと刺さっていて
とても 気にはなっていました
しかし それでも 私は
「新しい東北の創造」 —
このテーマについて
もっといろいろな人に知ってもらいたいと思い
同じ講演をしました
プログラムの最終日
私はハーバード大学で
日本に関心のある方々に
その講演をしていました
そして 講演が終わったあと
聴衆から 一人の日本人の男性が
私の元に来てくれました
そしてこのように話してくれました
「私は岩手県出身です
あなたの今のスピーチを聞いて
とても暖かい気持ちになりました
東北について こんな風に語ってくれる人が
いるなんて 知らなかったです
本当に 東北について話してくれて
ありがとうございます」
好きという気持ちが
自分の想いを強めてくれて
自分の想いが自分の夢へとなる
そして自分の想いと夢が
他の誰かの想いを育ててくれて
その人の想いがその人の夢へとなる
この想いの連鎖こそ
地域社会 そして世界を大きく変えていくと
私は信じています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）